[Música]
y mi segundo invitado el día mejor dicho
invitada el día ya no sé cómo
presentarlo se llama carmen mola pero
aquí en el estudio tenemos asentados a
tres hombres estamos hablando de jorge
agustín y antonio jorge porque carmen
mola pues porque hace unos años
decidimos entre tres amigos empezar un
experimento que era crear una escritora
y entonces que creamos esa escritora que
no iba a tener no iba a tener identidad
corpórea ok y entonces inventamos que se
va a llamar carne mónica como era
escritora nos vimos obligados a escribir
y entonces escribimos primero una novela
resultó que funcionaba muy bien que a la
gente le gustaba y escribimos una
segunda una tercera y bueno aquí estamos
en colombia encantados y presentando
nuestra cuarta novela que se llama la
bestia la bestia de la cual ya vamos a
hablar pero agustín y también esto este
seudónimo de carmen mola esta esta
identidad de esta creación de la
escritora le ha traído varias críticas
porque eso me gustaría saber la mente
bueno si surgieron como una serie de
críticas cuando ganamos el premio
planeta y salimos nosotros yo creo yo lo
pienso casi siempre como esta esta
sensación que uno tiene cuando una
novela se pasa a cine y el personaje que
te habías inventado en tu cabeza pues lo
interpreta un actor o una actriz no hay
mucha gente que se decepciona no con
esas y con ese cambio y eso fue un poco
lo que pasó en ese momento de repente la
gente había imaginado una carmen mola
concreta y cuando nos dieron el premio
pues claro no habían imaginado que
podríamos ser tres hombres pues buscó un
primer impacto de qué está pasando aquí
pero luego poquito a poco la novela se
fue abriendo sitio y se dejó de hablar
tanto de la polémica alrededor de la
carmen mola y pasamos a hablar de la
bestia que era lo que importaba en todo
caso antonio pues ustedes crearon la
bestia no firmaba por carmen mola pero
pues ya explicamos porque carmen mola
ahora hablemos un poco de este libro de
qué se trata que puede encontrar los
lectores en esta nueva novela bueno pues
en esta novela llevamos al lector al
madrid de
1834 un madrid que estaba siendo azotado
por una epidemia de cólera que esto no
suena un poco y también por la primera
guerra carlista que es una guerra de
sucesión en españa sobre quién tenía que
suceder a fernando séptimo si su hijita
pequeña isabel isabel segunda que tenido
siendo reina o su hermano carlos maría
sometió al país en una guerra y ese es
el contexto histórico de la mano de
lucia de una huerfanita de 14 años que
va buscando a su hermana desaparecida
nos metemos en un madrid embarrado
polvoriento y muy convulso y esa niña
pequeñita parece que ha caído en manos
de la bestia que es un asesino de niñas
del arrabal tocan un tema jorge pues
bien delicado y es pues esto de
cadáveres desmembrados niñas que nadie
reclama que aparecen en la calle y cómo
tocan esa problemática porque además que
pasan a día real
desgraciadamente pasa desgraciadamente
en la historia tenemos millones de
de acontecimientos en los que basarnos
desde los famosos sacamantecas que ha
habido en toda la historia de españa'
siempre para curar la tuberculosis con
los más recientes asesinatos que hemos
visto nosotros queremos denunciar esa
violencia contra la mujer muchas veces
contra la infancia nosotros queremos
fijarnos en un momento social en el que
una niña una niña pobre por montar más
datos vale lo mismo o un poco menos que
una gallina la gallina al fin y al cabo
pone huevos la niña no no da nada y
entonces queremos denunciar eso y situar
a esa niña en como protagonista de
nuestra novela como bueno realmente la
novela le hablamos muchas veces de la
violencia de la historia tal pero
realmente la novela es una niña que
busca a su hermana y que eso es lo más
importante una niña que se enfrenta a
todo que recorre una sociedad muy
violenta que recorre una sociedad muy
muy poco permeable hacia alguien con sus
problemas y de su clase social pero que
busca a su hermana y que eso es lo más
importante de todo y
yo a veces pienso en ese smartphone otra
vez
tenemos a lucia buscando a su hermana
también antonio está en esta historia un
policía y un periodista como ellos
ayudan y enriquecen esta historia de la
bestia si son dos personajes importantes
de la novela y además dos personajes que
representan algo un aspecto importante
de la novela es el año bisagra
1834 entre la edad antigua y la
modernidad la modernidad en la que
pasito a pasito iba entrando madrid y
españa en concreto el policía es una es
guardia real es un cuerpo del ejército
porque la policía se acababa de crear en
1834 y todavía no investigaba crímenes y
el periodista también representa los
albores del periodismo existía desde
unas décadas atrás tendrán periódicos
muy embrionarios de cuatro páginas muy
pequeñitos y no existía la figura del
periodista de investigación que en
realidad encarna diego que es un
buscavidas
esta mujer que quiere averiguar quién
está matando a esas niñas del arrabal
cuando el resto de los poderes fácticos
de la sociedad miran para otro lado no
les interesan nada así que son dos
personajes que nos ayudan a contar esta
etapa de cambio en el madrid el 19
agustín y también hay otro personaje muy
importante que es un monje si no me
equivoco
mujer guerrillero que pinte este monje
guerrillero en la bestia bueno al final
nosotros todos estos personajes el
periodista
un niño que ayuda que es un pícaro de la
ciudad que ayuda a lucía al principio
una madame de un burdel que es josefa la
leona que es otro personaje también
importante dentro de la novela o el
monje braulio no el este monje gar
guerrillero terminan representando como
una serie de estamentos de la sociedad
de madrid no eran reales esta cosa de
gay de un monje que se tiraba al monte a
hacer la guerra era algo real en españa
está sacado de personajes reales no y
entonces nos parece muy interesante que
nuestra protagonista no fuera
encontrando este tipo de ayudantes que
no son los mejores ayudantes pero que sí
bueno van dando pequeñas ayudas a lucia
a lo largo de su camino no hay que
representar determinadas cosas de la
sociedad el madrid de ese momento no
hasta cuándo ir a carmen mola es un
proyecto que tiene fecha de caducidad o
hasta que dure y yo creo que hay que el
destino la vida el momento no carmen
mola como hemos dicho desde el principio
de la van a matar es un juego me mola es
un juego y entonces a mí me gusta mucho
una comparación que siempre hace antonio
que dice esto es una fiesta
y en la fiesta hay que quedarse mientras
queda bebida mientras que la música y el
día que se acaba en la bebida a la
música deje de ser divertida pues
supongo que que armemos la dirá me voy a
casa pero creemos que para eso todavía
quedan años o sea que seguimos seguimos
con carmen mola piensa igual agustín y
piensa igual de hecho carmen mola ya
tiene un proyecto una novela que va a
salir una nueva novela que sale a
finales de septiembre principios de
octubre y es un proceso que disfrutamos
mucho levantar cada una de las novelas
es un proceso muy divertido las
reuniones estas revisiones de la que
hablábamos hasta que llegamos al
acabado de la novela y luego también
hemos tenido la suerte de que cuando nos
toque hacer promoción no lo pasamos bien
así que seguirán para rato carmen mola
carmen bola se la pasa bien a antonio sí
sí sí claro me mola se lo pasa bien
dicen que el éxito al autor al escritor
le puede traer un poco de melancolía
bueno pues en nuestro caso esa
melancolía todavía no se ha presentado
nos lo estamos pasando muy bien esto
está siendo intenso pero muy bonito y
queremos seguir no es fácil tener éxito
en el mundo literario ahora lo hemos
tenido hemos tenido esa suerte ojo
suerte porque el éxito es el gran
impostor
hemos mordido el hueso y no lo vamos a
soltar tan fácilmente bueno antonio
disfrutar entonces esos éxitos y pues
nada gracias igual por venir al estudio
france24 presentar esta nueva novela de
carmen mola llamada la bestia así que
pues si quieren enterarse de más de esta
trama pues compra esta novela y pues a
devorarse la bueno y yo creo que
bastante tiempo para para leerse la
depende de la lectura de cada uno por
aquí también tienen bastante tiempo para
para disfrutarlo porque son ya a ver si
son más de 530 y 500 cuántos 541 páginas
a pesar de eso hay gente que se la ha
devorado en dos días es seguro claro
claro claro yo digo un lector normal
como yo por ejemplo
yo no tengo mucho tiempo y
eso también puede puede ser y uno se le
va saboreando más pensando como claro
novela y toda la trabajo pues muchísimas
gracias jorge agustín a antonio por
estar con nosotros aquí en directo
américa de france 24